according to the ABC News affiliate in
Pittsburgh Senator John fetterman just
sent a letter to the CEO of Norfolk
Southern Railway
urging the company to help residents of
darling Township according to the
Pittsburgh Capital star Senator
fetterman just introduced legislation in
the Senate aimed at preventing future
Trend derailments like the one we saw in
East Palestine
but in reality Senator fetterman did
neither of those things because for the
past two weeks he's been isolated in a
psych ward allegedly for depression as
he has struggled to recover from a major
stroke
it is troubling that some staffer one
presumes has appointed himself senator
in fetterman's place it's even more
troubling that the establishment media
would publish this kind of propaganda
this absurd without even so much as
asking hmm
how did Senator fetterman do all those
things from his Hospital Ward but the
most troubling thing of all is that a
U.S senator can fail to function can
remove himself from the government
entirely
that a U.S president for that matter can
fail to function
and somehow the presence or absence of
those people
has no effect on the way the government
is run I'm Michael Knowles as the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show be sure to
smash that like button that's right
destroy that button with facts and logic
and subscribe and leave a comment
sometimes our friends on the big Tech
platforms don't love what we say so it's
always nice to kind of juice that
algorithm a little bit my favorite
comment yesterday is from jonelle
krajewski who says Michael's Dennis
Prager impression sounds more like a
discount Sean Connery
what do you mean blofeld
I uh you will never get away with it
blofeld
I will destroy your plans with the free
market
and with the power of religion
with the difference between men and
women I'm Sean Connery
I couldn't tell that should I do that
bit as Sean Connery or as Dennis Prager
I guess I ended up doing it as neither I
have to call my friend Dennis Prager and
apologize for that when you want to call
your friends you got to check out pure
talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com use code Knowles when times
get tough money's tight who can you rely
on did you know Pure Talk saves the
average family over 900 a year when they
switch from Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
instead of paying a fortune with your
current sell provider every month cut
your bill in half with pure talk you can
get unlimited talk text and plenty of
data for just 30 bucks a month Pure Talk
is so sure you're going to love their
service they're backing it up with a 100
money back guarantee switch over to Pure
Talk in as little as 10 minutes while
keeping your phone and your phone number
their us-based customer service team
makes the switch really easy besides the
fact that you're saving up to 900 a year
Pure Talk is a veteran-owned company
that shares your values and is the
antidote to woke wireless companies your
first month is guaranteed risk free go
to puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
kwles to save 50 off your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code Knowles
Canada wlas Pure Talk is simply
smarter
Wireless
doesn't seem to be a lot of democratic
oversight going on right now in
Pennsylvania or rather in the U.S Senate
regarding the senator from Pennsylvania
assuming John Federman is not actually
doing anything from his hospital room
then who's introducing this legislation
if John fetterman can't carry out the
duties of a senator and it's no knock on
him the guy should have been allowed to
recuperate from his stroke then
he needs to resign and we need a new
Senator and the people of Pennsylvania
ought to know that
people of the whole United States ought
to know that
but but increasingly we are seeing
a turning away from democratic oversight
particularly among Democrats there was a
woman
who went viral yesterday
she's an Arizona teacher explaining why
parents should have no right to control
the books that are on the curricula
their kids are being taught this
involves a bill called SB 1700 would
require the Arizona Department of
Education to maintain a list of books
that public educational institutions may
not use or make available to students
now before people start whining about
book bands and book burning and we need
to allow all books you know that that
isn't true first of all the most
important book in our whole civilization
is currently banned in schools you're
not allowed to teach the Bible in
schools which is absurd
but there are plenty of books that are
banned in schools or that have been
banned that should be banned pornography
you're not allowed to have a huge porn
collection in schools well at least you
weren't until recently now actually woke
teachers are smuggling in specifically
gay porn so this bill says you're not
allowed to have lewd or sexual books
books that promote gender fluidity or
gender pronouns or groom children or
normalize pedophilia and this bill
I'm just quoting from the text of the
bill by the way grants parents the right
to request removal of the school
district or Charter School library or
classroom materials extends public
review periods for Library materials and
District textbooks and removes
exceptions from District curriculum
approval and school library access
requirements really pretty basic stuff
parents have the right to not have their
kids exposed to weird creepy porn and
pedo stuff in the schools in the public
schools that their funding seems pretty
normal right one teacher says absolutely
not parents have no right to do this
because some parents don't even have a
master's degree
I have a master's degree because when I
got certified I was told I had to have a
master's degree to be an Arizona
certified teacher
we all have advanced degrees what do the
parents have are we vetting the
backgrounds of our parents are we
allowing the parents to choose the
curriculum and the books that our
children are going to read I think that
it's a mistake I'm just speaking from
the heart
um the one line that I love is uh we
must remember that the purpose of public
education is not to teach only what
parents want their children to be taught
it is to teach them what Society needs
them to be taught
we have master's degrees what do these
parents have right reason and proper
perception and a good formation and a
rational will and love for their
children
but they don't even have a master's
degree
I
do not wish to demean anybody's
educational accomplishments or
credentials or whatever
these degrees mean
nothing
they mean nothing a master's degree
means nothing
a bachelor's degree now means nothing
a PhD still
in many disciplines still means
something I guess but in some
disciplines actually not that much it
there are plenty of very smart good
normal people with master's degrees some
listen some of my best friends have
master's degrees okay but it doesn't
mean anything
and the fact that this woman
got her Master's Degree because she
needed that to get this job as a teacher
working to Peddle this crazy left-wing
agenda means that it means even less
than it ever did
what are we really talking about here
once you get past all the credentialism
and all the bureaucracy and all the
layers that the state has established to
mold your children's Minds
the question is hey
what should your kids learn
and if the lady with the Master's Degree
says your kids should be taught gay porn
in the fifth grade
then that does not speak very highly of
the credential but this is what they say
they say you don't if you don't have the
special credential
then you don't get to have a say about
how your kids are raised how your
government is conducted what your
immigration policy is what the foreign
policy is
nothing
the state of education is pretty sorry
right now I was having a conversation
with my friend Spencer Clavin just a
couple of nights ago and
Spencer Knows a thing or two about
education he has a PHD one of one of
those with a PhD who's one of the good
ones and Spencer Clavin mentioned a clip
to me and he said Michael you have to
see this clip it is so sad but but not
sad in the way that everybody else is
saying it's sad
I think like the biggest thing that like
annoys me in like the whole dating world
is like talking stages like that's so
annoying like the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing is just like what specifically
just like the fact of just like you like
I don't know how to word this
like in like talking stages and it's
just like you're like labeled that and
it's like people like are considered
like you can't like you're just like
confused and like most of the time like
the girl get but gets like attached or
something and they like see it like it's
going to lead to a relationship and it's
always not and it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
so the reason people think this is
really sad at the first layer is because
of what this young woman is describing
or at least attempting to describe which
is that women get used in this hookup
culture which now is referred to as
talking stages
like one would say euphemistically
oh we're not dating we're talking and
what are the talking stages sort of like
rounding first base second base that
would probably be the old way to talk
about it
but now there's not even a sense that
so-and-so is my girlfriend so-and-so is
my boyfriend it's just oh yeah we're
talking we're doing this we're doing
that
you know you don't really know there's
no commitment here and so she's
lamenting this and so that's sad
the somewhat deeper reason that people
are
saying that this is a very sad clip is
because the woman is not the most
articulate
so people are kind of making fun of the
woman for speaking this way I am not
making fun of her she seems like a
perfectly nice girl she's describing a
serious problem and she's doing it as
best she can and if she is a person
under the age of 50 in America then she
has had probably a pretty crappy
education and that's not her fault if
she's not totally articulate
the deepest reason though that I think
this is a really sad clip is that that
one line there where she says I don't
know how to say this I don't know how
and this woman is using the same five or
six words for the whole clip
and she's struggling there's something
that she wants to express that she can't
express because she doesn't know the
words to use to express the thing that
she is perceiving and feeling
that's what sir said and it's it's an
issue that I talk about all the time
it's the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is available there we are we have
it
if you can't articulate a problem
you can't solve the problem
language
establishes the limits and Contours of
our thought of our consciousness of the
way that we perceive and conceive of the
world
not just what we think but what we even
can think I'll give you a great example
of this that I was thinking about just
the other day in the Italian language
there is no word in Italian for privacy
when Italians talk about privacy they
just say la privacy
they use the English word which tells
you a lot about the Italian culture
tells you something serious about the
Italian culture which is that Italians
don't value privacy in any way and never
have
so if they're going to refer to this
concept they refer to it as a foreign
concept and they use a foreign word if
your culture doesn't have a word for
privacy then your culture is not going
to have privacy
the fact that the Liberals control our
language they do their best to shape our
language and make us use stupid pronouns
and tell us we can't say all sorts of
words the reason they do this is not
just because they're scolds the reason
they do this is not because they're
neopuritans necessary exactly not
entirely at least the reason they do
this is because they know that if they
take certain words out of our vocabulary
and they twist the meaning of other
words it's going to completely warp the
way that we view the world we won't even
be able to express our dissatisfaction
and our objections to the things that
they are doing
this liberalism in the air it's just
it's like a pollutant just constantly
all over the air when you want to get
pollutants out of your air you've got to
check out rabbit air head on over to
rabbitair.com say Michael Knowles sent
you I adore all of my sponsors I adore
them all
it's like children I don't pick
favorites however
sometimes in some circumstances
some
sponsors much like certain children can
really show their medal can really be
very convenient and helpful
and that would be rabbit air when I am
smoking a stogie rabbit airs
award-winning air purifiers are at the
top of the line some of the best in the
industry they've got Advanced six stage
filtration and deodorization that can
reduce Airborne particles odors and
pollutants to keep your air clean and
fresh this air purifier is extremely
customizable it's got an interchangeable
face plate design wall mount floor stand
for custom filtration options for odor
remover cigars toxin absorber for vocs
all of it you can do it on your phone
smart sensing technology it's just
unbelievable it's so good you know how
much I love stogies I got in my office
right now it is
by far the best air filtration system I
have ever used it's not even close
especially if you love cigars visit
rabbitair.com to speak to a rabbit air
consultant that is
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com don't forget to
check out their artists series and
special editions for more aesthetically
placing product design make sure to tell
them that Michael Knowles sent you
speaking of the importance of symbols my
man over in El Salvador naibukele the
president of El Salvador
another great propaganda video out we
played earlier this week a propaganda
video from the El Salvadoran president
of all these MS-13 gangsters just being
hauled around this giant prison like
insects looking so weak so humiliated
then there was a an answer video to that
the kind of complementary video to that
was the president addressing the Army
troops who have rounded up all these
gangsters and it was bright and it was
inspiring and he was talking about God
and it was great now we've got another
propaganda video
it's a propaganda video of the president
sending these gangster prisoners To Go
destroy tombstones that have MS-13
symbols on them
I love this video you see their Ms right
there on a tombstone and you'll see too
the symbolism of Santa Muerte all this
occult demonic downright satanic
symbolism which has always been
associated with MS-13 MS-13 has a deeply
satanic element to it and so what does
the president do he not only destroys
their monuments these occult criminal
gangster
satanic monuments
he has the gangsters do it themselves he
forces them to do this
is this authoritarian
I guess as I've said before I don't
really know what that word means as far
as I can tell the word authoritarian is
just the word to describe one's
political opponents whenever whenever we
do something in politics that's good
that's wonderful that's that's very
liberal that's great but when our
opponents do something in politics
that's always authoritarian so sure call
it authoritarian this is my kind of
authority baby because the president in
El Salvador is the legitimate civil
Authority
he inherited this massive problem where
there was a rival power the Rival power
to the duly elected government is the
gangsters these these absolute Devils
who rape kill pillage and burn and so
what does the president do he says we're
gonna get rid of their power and not
only are we going to round them up and
not only are we going to cut off their
Commerce we're going to humiliate them
and we're going to destroy their symbols
and their gravestones we're going to
desecrate everything about these people
because there's nothing sacred about
what they're doing
everything they do is sacrilegious in
fact
really important
and the squishes don't quite get this
the squishes are the kinds who will say
oh who cares
whether you call a man he or she who
cares let's talk about something
important like taxes come on let's talk
about something that really matters like
the deficit or whatever
who cares if we call a man he or she
well
the libs care that's why they spend so
much time focusing on it
and they care because symbols matter
symbols
might be the most important thing in
politics these symbols are how we
communicate with one another symbols are
what binds a community together
if someone comes in and controls all the
symbols
changes all the symbols to to
better job with their political program
then they're going to control the
political order
so buchale knows it's not enough
to just round up the physical criminals
you've got to change the symbols too and
that that changes the meaning of our
political communities Hershey's showed
this just just yesterday
or she shared this with the
her for she campaign
her for she campaign was for
international women's day and what
Hershey did was they went all feminist
but there was a Twist on it they went
feminist
and then cast a man dressed as a woman
in the role of the woman for
international women's day
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
I know
I know everyone knows
it's so offensive in every way to every
group it seems
it's so offensive that you know
it crossed Jeremy's mind right you know
so actually some of you tweeted it at us
he said this company this judge just
won't eat my chocolate but this company
is just rubbing my face in this stupid
not only woke feminist ideology but this
woke trans feminist I uh you know it
crossed Jeremy's mind
but you probably thought
there's no way
there's no way but Jeremy
would actually launch
a chocolate company if he'd if he did
there's no way that he would do it
on the very day that Hershey's launched
the trans campaign right
well just because we launched Jeremy's
razors after Harry's canceled
conservatives took on Disney with hiring
Gina Carano after they canceled or sued
the federal government over the vax
Mandate and won
people think
that we can just take on every woke
company when they make these ridiculous
statements of course we can't do that
every time
or can we
[Music]
you might be thinking how could you have
launched a chocolate company in one day
well they don't call him the god king
for nothing don't wait pre-order your
Jeremy's chocolate now
at ihatehersheys.com
that is ihatehersheys.com
get your he him and she her chocolate
bars today yet another way to stop
giving your money to woke corporations
that hate you
back to Hershey's for a second
Hershey's Hershey's
made an error here I think and irritated
a lot of the customers but they they
exposed something that a lot of people
don't understand about the way our
culture works a lot of people believe
that the problem that our society faces
is that we put too much value on our
bodies on material Goods on the stuff of
this world we deny the soul we deny
metaphysical morality we deny we deny
everything right
no
what what this Hershey's ad and
transgenderism broadly what what it
shows you is that increasingly we think
the body doesn't matter at all
increasingly
we live our lives digitally increasingly
we live our lives on our phones or in
the metaverse or online Internet forums
and so we don't think the Body Matters
we think it can all be we Zoom we Skype
It's All Digital we work from home
now this is where the meme of go touch
grass comes from people saying go put
down the screens go outside go do
something go do something in the real
world with real people in real time in
space
because if we live our lives as though
the body doesn't matter we're going to
come to think that the body doesn't
matter Lexa Randi likes credenti
if we if we live our lives just like
couch potatoes plugged into the Matrix
where we do everything digitally
then then
we're not only are we going to accept
trans ideology we're going to accept all
of it even if we don't want to because
belief follows
our Behavior and the rituals that we
engage in no surprise here from
Hershey's but it's something that we
should all watch out for
we need some accountability remember
that word we were taught to have it from
a young age or we should have been but
if we weren't then we think the world
revolves around us and that's not
healthy for anybody as we are witnessing
every day but don't take my word for it
listen to this clip from Jordan
Peterson's new five-part series vision
and Destiny only on daily wire Plus
it's unpopular children who say oh well
the game is only going to be the one I
want to play
and those children other children just
move away from there they they alienate
and isolate them instantly and they go
look for other play Partners those kids
are no fun
and and it's because they're too
insistent that their subjective State
dominate the social space and that's
exactly what's happening on the identity
politics front it's like well I feel I'm
this way and you better treat me like
that or else it's like you are a bad
little kid you're a kid that never
learned how to play and you're being
fostered in your juvenile delusion by
your narcissistic virtue signaling
parents who aren't sensible enough to
help you guide yourself towards the
establishment of an identity that would
allow you to be appreciated by other
children
the third episode of vision and Destiny
is out today new episodes are releasing
every week but it's all exclusive for
daily wire Plus members join out
dailywire.com subscribe to watch vision
and Destiny
you know speaking of the weird sex stuff
I've got to get there's just one story I
want to get to before before the mailbag
which is a guy
is it his name is Julio Cesar bear Mejo
he's a Peruvian man 26 year old who owns
a mummy
it's got this 800 year old mummy and he
keeps the mummy in a food delivery bag
and he calls The Mummy his spiritual
girlfriend and says the mummy's name is
Juanita
and
he was in for a big surprise he was
discovered having a picnic with his
mummy uh The Mummy with whom he sleeps
every night takes care of the Mummy he
says it sleeps in my bedroom with me
there's my bed the TV set next to it
there's Juanita I take care of it it's
like if you'll pardon the expression as
if it were my spiritual girlfriend and
so he was in for a big surprise because
the authorities took them on me when
they found it and they did a an analysis
of it and it turns out
Juanita was more likely one
it's a male mummy I don't know if this
is causing any psychological trauma for
Julios or bermejo I assume he's got
other psychological problems here the
question I have
for all the people who object to the
Social and cultural conservatives
obviously the libs but even the squishes
on the right even the people who say oh
Live and Let Live who cares I don't want
no I'm not don't yuck my yum if it if it
doesn't hurt anybody if it's just
consenting adults who cares
why is this against the law
if that's your perspective and if you're
saying that when we try to legislate
morality and legislate views of the good
the true and the Beautiful and that's
terrible and authoritarian and
anti-American and wrong in every way
then why should this be against the law
to sleep with an 800 year old mummy
every night and take out the mummy and
call The Mummy your spiritual girlfriend
why can't Julio Cesar birmejo keep his
mummy boyfriend
if that's your view
the conservatives have an answer to that
which is that it's wrong and disordered
and creepy and weird and he needs to be
normal and needs to get some help and he
and the law has to say no no mummy
boyfriend for you Julio you can't do
that
no you need a human
boyfriend or girlfriend if you're going
to have one at all
but what about
the libs
and the squishes and the you do you as
long as it doesn't hurt anybody else
it's a bag of bones it's 800 years old
and especially if you think that the
human soul is imaginary and there's no
God and there's no Heaven there's no
there's no carrots it's a bag of bones
like what's wrong with it what's wrong
with The Mummy boyfriend
we finally arrived at my favorite time
of the week this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter code noltz kwles get 50 off
your first month take it away with the
voicemail bag
good morning Mr Knowles I'm reaching out
for your advice on a topic involving my
best friend of 20 plus years he uh
recently was trying to cheat on his wife
with my mother of all people he was
sending her lewd messages uh saying
things like nobody has to know obviously
meaning me
um I know he and his wife have gone
through a lot she said postpartum
depression I know they haven't gotten
along very well lately I think a lot of
that's what drove him to this I'm not
making excuses but I'm trying to give
you as much as I can here
um as a Christian man I I feel like as a
friend I should help him through this
dark time in his life with his marriage
but at the same time I don't want to
talk to him I certainly don't want to
see him and I'm just wondering as a man
of God what do you feel like my
responsibility here should be thank you
so much God bless
when you started out asking that
question I assumed it was a troll and it
was
but by the you sounded sincere so maybe
this actually is happening
well I guess what I would do is
maybe send him a text
you're right I don't think I'd want to
go have a beer with him
I don't think I would want to
to even talk on the phone with him maybe
send him a text though and say
hey man
you should not cheat on your wife and
you certainly shouldn't sleep with my
mother
or proposition her at all
and you should seek help
from a psychologist and confess your
sins to a priest
and then act normal it's just like the
last story I did it's this is
unbelievable how many political problems
would be solved if people just
acted normal
and understood that that is a legitimate
political
request
especially on the right because the
right denies norms and and standards
because we now say oh listen you know
don't I don't want the government coming
in and telling me what to do or whatever
so we we deny that norms and standards
exist or taboos exist but obviously they
do you shouldn't violate them this is
one of them I don't know if your parents
are still married
and so he's telling your mother to cheat
on her husband with him or if she's
widowed or divorced or something but in
any case it's just all so disordered and
just say bro get help and be normal and
stop being a degenerate and a weirdo and
a creep lovingly your friend
so and so next question
dear Michael A friend of mine and I had
a conversation discussing morality and I
could really use your help for the next
time it comes up I argue that morality
does not change based on the person or
situation he argued that is a religious
belief and things like abortion can be
justified my problem came trying to
explain why morality is absolute when
people have different beliefs I know you
have covered similar topics on the show
and I could really use your help in
articulating my thoughts I know right
from wrong but when asked why I feel
that my justifications fell short
sincerely speechless controlling words
controlling Minds really good question
and you're absolutely right morality is
objective and it does not vary based on
situation the morality of an action does
not change based on say the consequences
that that could result from it
now if I heard you right what you said
is your friend's objection was well no
no morality is religious
and therefore you can't make an argument
against abortion
and he's half right morality is
religious
everything ultimately is religious but
but
it can be objectively true or
objectively false the reason your friend
might be forgiven for his ignorance
is because many many people have bought
into this lie and it it derives frankly
from the way that we talk about
religious freedom the way that we talk
about religious freedom today is very
different than the way people talked
about religious freedom in the past
in the past people talked about
religious freedom as a matter of
prudence and toleration
that we're not going to be leading
Crusades and pogroms all the time we're
not we don't want bloody Conflict for 30
years between the Catholics and the
Protestants we don't want all that stuff
and so we're going to exercise
a decent degree of religious toleration
not the people who promoted this idea by
the way did not suggest total religious
toleration
or I'll even take the word religious out
of it the Toleration of say Satanism or
something like that or atheism that the
people who advocated religious
toleration explicitly rejected that idea
but they said you know people whose
religious practices differ a little bit
we're gonna we'll do that as a matter of
prudence
but all religions are not equally true
some religions make claims that are
truer than others and ultimately only
one religion could be true inasmuch as
that religion contradicts other
religions and and so to say well that
claim is religious yeah well sure it is
but is it true or is it false uh Matthew
Patric has a great little diagram in a
book about how to think about this
on one level you've got politics we're
talking about political issues like
abortion on another level this this is
the level actually that politics is
resting on you have applied morality how
do we apply moral Concepts to situations
beneath that you've got morality broadly
the moral order
beneath that you've got
epistemology
how do we know things at all
beneath that you've got anthropology
what is human nature
who who are we knowing creatures beneath
that you've got ontology what is what
does it mean to be and beneath that
you've got theology
which is ultimately what it all comes
down to
what is
what is real what is the basis of
reality so yeah that's what I would say
you say it's true and so you've got to
go through all of those stages and if it
comes down to a religious question yeah
that's no surprise everything does next
question
hello Michael this is Dr Ann lesby head
of gender studies at ACL University
I wish I could say it's a pleasure
speaking with you but that is not true
as a semi-trans non-binary fluid
neurodivergent woman of color I find
interaction with an intersectional
oppressor such as yourself deeply
repulsive and triggering
unfortunately there is an urgent
question I feel I must ask
several days ago Ari Drennan the lgbtq
w-i-i-a-a-n-b-k-p-p-s-2 plus program
director at Media Matters publicly
exposed your unspeakably horrific plan
to genocide trans people by denying them
access to things like gender affirming
care vaginoplasty and women's bathrooms
in response to Ms Drennan you launched a
vicious gaslighting social media attack
on her denying your own genocidal
statements falsely referring to her as
your publicist and inciting your rage
mob of multi-phobic fascist followers to
engage in malicious mockery of Miss
Drennan for hours on end but this was
not enough was it Michael you then
issued a logbook invitation for Ari to
debate you on your own show
so this is my question how in good
conscience assuming you have one
can you expect a victim of threatened
genocide violent verbal assault and
rampant misgendering to appear with you
on your program
I await your reply
thank you for the question Dr lesby
how could I have such an expectation I
suppose because Hope Springs Eternal in
the human breast
though as you can see I do not have
breasts and so perhaps
I should Harbor no such hope
next question
Michael you said that Trump and
Republicans should not be talking about
the stolen elections so long as everyone
ignores how Democrats Are Ringing
elections we will never win 2020 and 22
prove the effectiveness of their methods
no party in history wins 51 of the vote
when 75 percent of the country is
against their policies
provisional ballots cast with that ID
deliberately mixed in with legitimate
pouts used to be their best method of
fraud through multiple voting days now
they just use anonymous mail balls that
are 100 fraud because you don't know who
fills them out and keep on Counting
until they win
there's only one solution to this one
election day with only in-person voting
only with photo ID proof of citizenship
if no one talks about this and stops
Democrat selection rigging we will
become a one-party Marshals dictatorship
wherein Republicans are just there to be
scapegoats this won't be solved in
corrupt courts that won't hear proof
will we spread the word or just accept
Democrats squelching the truth mocking
Patriots as conspiracy nuts
uh good question I think you may have
misunderstood what I said or maybe I was
not clear in what I said I do not
believe that Republicans should stop
talking about all the ways that the libs
rig the elections I think it's important
to talk about that it's more important
though to just fix it to go in and
change the rules so that the Democrats
don't give themselves such a big
advantage
and when I'm talking about the way Trump
should speak
I just don't think he should focus on it
I think the Trump
running for the Republican primary in
should focus on passing Big Macs out to
the people of East Palestine Ohio and
should talk about trade
and should talk about foreign policy and
should should talk about things that
directly affect people's day-to-day
lives and that that doesn't mean that
you ignore the ways that the libs rig
the vote
doesn't mean that you never mention it
certainly doesn't mean you don't do
anything about it it just in terms of
what people want to hear in terms of I
think what will help Donald Trump win
the Republican nomination as he wants to
do and then win a general election I
think he's going to get a lot more
support if he focuses on the way that
the Biden Administration is allowing a
town in Ohio to be poisoned without
doing anything about it and and talks
more about the disastrous foreign policy
and the open border and the complete
offshoring of American manufacturing all
the rest of it I think I think that's
going to be more compelling to people
than going back and complaining about
all the ways that the libs rigged the
election
no matter no matter how much or how
little the libs read the election I just
think that message is not going to
resonate quite as well and this is
coming from me who I I am as persuaded
as one can be of all sorts of
Shenanigans in 2020. the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles kwels at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you